CBS News has learned the Justice
Department is pushing AT&T to sell CNN
as part of its merger with Time Warner
the 85 billion dollar deal needs
approval from antitrust regulators but
the focus on CNN is raising concern
about political interference president
Trump has repeatedly bashed the cable
channel fake news CNN fake you are fake
news Julianna Goldman is in Washington
with what's at stake Julianna good
morning good morning well during the
campaign President Trump promised to
stop the merger on antitrust grounds
saying that it's too much concentration
of power in the hands of too few but a
person familiar with the matter told CBS
News that White House officials have
made it clear to AT&T on multiple
occasions that they're dissatisfied with
CNN and in one case sources say that in
January
president-elect Trump raised the matter
directly with AT&T CEO Randall
Stephenson during a meeting at Trump
Tower now the White House denies
involvement in the negotiations and the
Justice Department says that AT&T itself
offered to divest CNN and that the
government flatly rejected it but AT&T
CEO said he never offered to sell CNN
and has no intention of doing so
so sources say AT&T is preparing to take
the administration to court arguing that
the deal doesn't pose any competition
violations now Gail Democrats in
Congress even who are opposed to the
merger like Al Franken the senator from
Minnesota say that if the Trump
administration is pressuring AT&T to
divest CNN it would be a disturbing
development all right a lot of people
feel that way thank you very much
Julianna